what was that youtube heroes no I
haven't heard of it oh it took a new
feature oh cool cool wait is that just
like some kind of ploy to get people to
moderate the website for them so they
don't have to pay professionals oh okay
okay you're right here right no
something sounds really cool YouTube
heroes wow sounds awesome i'll check it
out for sure it see ya oh cool upbeat
music that must mean it's great yeah I
work hard why not deserve a place to
call home mass flagging videos aww I
mean that must be good if it's for a
good cause right yeah I can be a hero I
can be a hero I can be a hero
for years they laughed at me they said
stop playing with Japanese swords and
wasting your time complaining about
comments on YouTube and get a real job
but I always knew that my mission was to
make the world a better place on YouTube
and now finally I have my chance finally
someone recognizes my potential my
greatness finally I can be a hero put
this away there's no purpose to my
YouTube job all right jennamarbles did
another rant that's awesome I love her
oh wait did she just use the f-word what
if my mom saw this video like swear
words make her very uncomfortable I'm
sorry Jenna I have to flag this video
I'll leafyishere this channel is so
popular I heard so much about it I
better check it out what
what is this but this is an advertiser
friendly content this isn't friendly at
all Oh flag flag masts flag masts flag
haha I can't believe how many YouTube
channels don't have advertiser friendly
content it's my duty as the YouTube hero
to flag them all rice come flag keemstar
flag fire a cynical flag Grande under a
flag filthy Frank flag scarce nobody
cares about scarce PewDiePie flag I dubs
flag lost boss flag Billy the French
flag flag flag flag
haha
bye